[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys
gruselwelt heute gibt es was ist ein
Rezept für Halloween denn einige von
euch haben sich tatsächlich Rezepte dazu
gewünscht ich hatte eine Umfrage
gestartet heute gibt es gruselige
Brownies die richtig lecker schmecken
weil sie eine Cheesecake Füllung
bekommen es kommen falsches mit rein
also das ganze wird echt lecker und ich
habe mir gedacht ich lege die später so
auf den blutbett hier glaube ich ein
bisschen zu viel Horror und Thriller
gelesen aber ich glaube das ganze wird
ganz lecker und sehr sehr schön also
gruselig schön muss ich sagen ja
jedenfalls wird jetzt erstmal der
Brownie Teig hergestellt dafür verwende
ich 180 Gramm Butter 150 Gramm
Zartbitterschokolade 150 g Zucker etwas
Salz und Vanilleextrakt 3 Eier 150 Gramm
Mehl und 60 Gramm Kakao
gebt ihr zuerst einmal die Butter in
einen Topf und schmelzt sie über dem
warmen Herd
auf dem Herd Stufe wow ihr könnt es aber
auch in der Mikrowelle machen bei
geringer Hitze
jetzt einfach drauf achten nicht zu heiß
werden lassen damit gleich noch die
Schokolade dazu kann und die soll er
nicht verbrennen die soll einfach nur
schmelzen in der Restwärme
[Musik]
wenn die Butter geschmolzen ist gebt ihr
die Kuvertüre rein schaltet aber vorher
den Herd aus
[Musik]
dann habe ich jetzt hier die
Schokoladenmasse die ist jetzt auch gar
nicht heiß ich habe tatsächlich auch
extra dafür die emailschüssel benutzt
weil die die Hitze und aber auch die
Kälte immer schnell transportiert also
die Temperatur schnell ausgleicht das
heißt ich kann jetzt hier gleich wieder
weitermachen und alle restlichen Zutaten
einfach kurz mit dem Schneebesen
einrühren
[Musik]
jetzt einfach kurz alles einrühren
wird
Espresso rein
das mache ich
[Musik]
also wenn der Tee noch zu warm ist und
mein Papa aber weg muss dann macht er
immer so von einer Taste in die nächste
damit er da so
lauwarm
[Musik]
oh nein habe jetzt echt verschüttet muss
lag jetzt nicht
[Musik]
und der Größe der Rührschüssel sondern
daran dass ich jetzt den Kaffee direkt
einrühren sollen mit den Flüssigkeiten
aber passiert als backanfängerin kann
das einem auch schon mal passieren
also am besten verrührte erstmal alle
Flüssigkeiten und dann verrührt ihr die
trockenen Zutaten und dann habt ihr
diesen wundervollen Teig
[Musik]
die Halloween lache
der Espresso war perfekt dafür
für die Füllung verwende ich 175 Gramm
Frischkäse ein Ei etwas Vanilleextrakt
20g Zucker und 100 Gramm Faches dann
nehme ich jetzt hier die cookido-tsches
verrührt ihr auch hier alle Zutaten
miteinander gibt es auch keine bestimmte
Reihenfolge wobei bei dem Brownies Teig
gab es eine nicht mehr korrigieren
erste flüssigen Zutaten dann die
trockene dazu aber hier könnt ihr
wirklich alles miteinander verrühren
Hauptsache klümpchenfrei
[Musik]
das denn heute los heute wieder nur
gekleckert hier
da fällt der Löffel einfach neben die
Löffel Ablage
heute ist so typischer erster April
jetzt habe ich den Ofen bereits
vorgeheizt auf 180°c
und da kommt jetzt erstmal die Hälfte
des schokoteiges rein
[Musik]
da kommt jetzt die Cheesecake Masse rein
und da gebt ihr jetzt noch die fettes
drauf und bedeckt das ganze dann den
restlichen Teig
den Klecks sich jetzt so ein bisschen
gleichmäßig drauf und versuche es dann
zu verstreichen falls ich es doch
bisschen vermischt ist nicht schlimm
wenn ihr wollt dass es aber komplett
abgedeckt ist dann verteilt es ganz
vorsichtig und gleichmäßig denn die
Cheesecake Masse ist doch recht flüssig
aber wie gesagt wenn sich so ein
bisschen marmoriert das ist auch nicht
schlimm
[Musik]
so sieht der Brownie super aus da kommt
jetzt auch schon direkt in den Backofen
der darf später in der Mitte schon noch
so ein bisschen bei der Stäbchenprobe
feucht sein und weil ich finde das so
ein Brownie relativ süß schokoladig und
matschig ist so wie eben gehört finde
ich passt da jetzt so eine fruchtige
saure Komponente dazu deswegen koche ich
jetzt gleich die Fruchtsoße
[Musik]
für die Fruchtfüllung nehme ich jetzt
hier einfach tiefgefrorene Himbeeren
frische gibt es ja momentan nicht
deswegen gerne auf Tiefkühlkost
zurückgreifen
dann 50 Gramm Zucker dazu und etwas
trockener Paste weil es geschmacklich
einfach perfekt passt
ihr könnt gerne am Anfang damit ein
bisschen schneller geht auch bisschen
war Wasser dazugeben heißes Wasser müsst
ihr aber nicht das schmilzt ja auch hier
jetzt ganz schnell und ich zerdrückt es
jetzt gleich auch mit dem Walker dann
habe ich gleich ein schönes buchpüree
und wer möchte kann es dann noch gerne
durch den Sieb streichen damit eben die
Kerne auch entfernt werden
[Musik]
jetzt ist der Brownie abgekühlt ich kann
ihn jetzt hier rauslösen und werde schon
mal parallel Marshmallows schmelzen in
der Mikrowelle ihr könnt es aber auch
gerne in der Pfanne machen aber in der
Mikrowelle ist ein bisschen einfacher
einfach höchste Stufe eine Minute das
reicht schon
denn die Marshmallows werden gleich
schwimmweben
und ich so ich mache Halloween Rezepte
weil ihr euch wünscht
okay die Marshmallows
sind geschmolzen
ihr müsst da tatsächlich aufpassen dass
ihr nicht verbrennen
[Musik]
vielleicht auch nicht bei höchster Stufe
wir sind überfahren UPS
vielleicht nehmen wir einfach niedrige
Stufe
600 Watt eine Minute das reicht ja damit
sie nicht verbrennen
und wenn sie ganz dick und fluffig und
luftig werden
wisst ihr dass sie geschmolzen sind
und jetzt bitte nicht die Hände
verbrennen dann nehmt ihr euch die
Marshmallow Masse
zieht sie so ein bisschen auseinander
kennt ihr vielleicht noch von der Torte
vom letzten Jahr und dann setzt ihr die
Spinnweben über den Brownie
[Musik]
zum buddy
no one need somebody help
jetzt wird's tatsächlich wie
Sekundenkleber
[Musik]
könntest du mir bitte die Tür aufmachen
ja
jetzt
paar Sekunden
oh mein Gott Anna
[Musik]
leider habe ich keine gruselaugen mehr
aber diese Augen tun auch
kommen jetzt noch so ein paar
zuckeraugen nämlich drauf
und vielleicht ein paar Spinnen
[Musik]
toll da haben wir noch ein paar Spinnen
auf bitte
kannst du mir kurz einen Frischkäse
rausgeben
[Gelächter]
ich finde schon allein durch die Augen
einfach süß aus
[Musik]
okay das war meine kleine große Sauerei
denn es wird jetzt ein blutbett
für die Brownies
und eigentlich will ich so draufschlagen
ne das mache ich jetzt aber lieber mit
dem
okay bereit
[Musik]
ich will eigentlich machen ich mag keine
Sorgen in der Küche
hoppala hat man da jemanden ermordet
[Musik]
ja das ist Halloween
und da kommen jetzt die Brownies gleich
drauf oh mein Gott die Platte sieht so
gut aus wie so ein Kunstwerk kommt
gleich Jutta und sagt wer hat die
Sauerei wieder gemacht und sage ich
Jutta heute bist du Tatortreiniger bitte
sie denkt bestimmt wieder an hat sich
verletzt
[Musik]
also ich würde es nicht sagen hier da
kommt der Psycho in mir raus sondern da
kommt der Künstler in mir raus
[Musik]
ich natürlich immer so eine Grenze zu
naja überlasse ich euch ich glaube so
ein Brownie auf dem Buffet
kommt schon gut
zugegeben ich bin ein bisschen
ausgeartet und ich verstehe es auch wenn
Menschen Halloween eklig finden
so langsam sind ist es für mich okay
alles andere was blutig ist finde ich
auch eklig
ja und ich kann so viel mehr und Horror
Sachen also Horror kann ich nicht gucken
Psycho und Thriller kann ich schon
gucken und auch lesen also ich lese
total gerne Psycho aber es darf nicht
echt sein nicht auf wahrer Begebenheit
wenn es auf wahrer Begebenheit ist kann
ich es nicht schauen weil ich dann das
verkraftet mein Verstand anders das ist
Menschen gibt die schlimmes tun aber
solange es in der Fiktion ist und
Himbeeren als Blut bis alles okay so
jetzt kommt noch ein halloweenexperte
das ist der Toga
[Applaus]
man kann diese Brownies also ich glaube
ich finde man kann einfach so ein cooles
Halloween Dessert Buffet machen oder
halt herzhaft auch
und dann ich lege euch auch dieses
Kunstblut als Rezept an und dann könnt
ihr nämlich noch hergehen und mit so
Einwegspritzen und die mit der Küche
mehr Weg benutzen kann
zack
dann machst du hier noch so
jetzt Vorsicht
dann schneide ich dir den Brownie an
das ist so ein Highlight auf jeder
Halloween Party ich sag's dir ich habe
so Lust auf Halloween Partys jetzt
ich glaube ich schmeiße eine echt ja
Spinnweben von unserem Set
das sieht richtig cool
[Musik]
aus
[Gelächter]
so jetzt können wir probieren ja
ich hasse Spinnen aber ich liebe hallo
ich will ja nur eins sagen eigentlich so
ein bisschen paradox weil er wirklich
vor der kleinsten kleinsten mini-baby
Spinne Angst hat gefährlich ja aber
so eine Mörder in so einem Thriller der
ist ungefähr
lecker ja aber ja diesen Umfeld
ist dann
[Musik]
natürlich nett
schon
[Gelächter]
nein
für mich braucht es noch ein bisschen
mehr Blut also du kannst dir ruhig dann
so
rein
[Musik]
einfach so zack kannst du rein und dann
perfekt ne also ihr könnt ja gerne mal
schreiben ob ihr diese Idee cool findet
und generell ob ihr dieses Jahr eine
Halloween Party schmeißt ob es was zum
Thema gibt muss sagen eigentlich hat es
mich gewundert dass die Ella keine
Halloween Party wollte ich habe sie
nämlich gefragt werde am 24 Oktober
Geburtstag und dann habe ich da was
hättest du denn gerne für eine Torte und
hat zuerst Katze und jetzt ist aber voll
auf Pokémon das heißt ja bald geht es
auf dem Kanal was zu Pikachu denn sie
ist gerade voll im pikachu-fieber ich
war ja Team Katze aber dann packe ich
mir selber eine katzentorte für mich und
für Muffin ja und für Anna
Katzen Geburtstagsparty ja jedenfalls
gibt es dieses Rezept auf meinem Blog
auf meiner App auf sallys-blog.de schaut
euch gerne mal an und ich bin schon
gespannt auf eure Rückmeldungen auf
jeden Fall jetzt noch eine Halloween
Torte geben das verspreche ich Euch und
wir verkleiden und schminken uns
ich bin dabei
also bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
das müssen wir einfach so wie es ist
fotografieren
[Musik]